if you're struggling to cut proper
slices you've got to start using the
back slice have you ever sliced
something and then this happens it
sticks to the knife you've got to change
the way you slice instead of chopping
start slicing like this angle the tip of
the knife on the cutting board and rest
the blade against your knuckles then
pull back while maintaining the same
angle this way whatever you're slicing
doesn't stick to the blade and you'll
get perfect slices every time
this is how you can turn your homemade
kimchi into a crunchy grilled cheese all
right 150 grams raw milk cheddar 150
grams kimchi 2 chopped spring onions and
one egg mix together use four slices of
sourdough to form two sandwiches butter
the other sides add the filling and
close the sandwich then fry for two
minutes on each side while weighing them
down with the pastel and water just like
that
a homemade wine schnitzel brush some
cling film with oil then cover the veal
with another layer pound until half a
centimeter thick let's spread the
schnitzel brush both sides with water
and season with salt then gently cover
with flour and shake off the excess turn
into lightly beaten eggs and finally
coat with breadcrumbs melt 150 grams of
butter in a pan skim off the froth then
pour into a jug making sure to leave the
leftover milk solids behind heat the
clarified butter in a pan and fry the
schnitzel for one minute on both sides
shaking the pan so that the hot butter
runs over the top then serve with a
slice of lemon and a dollop of mustard
this is an easy way to make kimchi at
home make a brine with 50 grams salt and
1 liter of water add all of the veg to a
bowl and pour over the brine
leave for 24 hours drain the veg but
keep the brine then rinse under cold
water and squeeze out the moisture 10
garlic cloves 20 grams ginger one
shallot and 70 milliliters of water
blend it to a paste and add to the
vegetables along with hundred grams
kochu junk mix together then pack into a
jar top it up with a bit more of the
brine then leave the ferment for several
days making sure to submerge the top
every day until it tastes sour and
begins to bubble
this homemade lemonade will get you
through the hottest summer days all
right try to find some of the leaves on
they're so fragrant peel the zest of 5
lemons and juice the fruits to get
around 300 milliliters slightly break a
handful of leaves to release the aroma
then slice around 40 grams of ginger 100
grams cane sugar 750 milliliters water
add the lemon peels along with the
leaves and the ginger slowly bring to a
boil then turn off the heat and leave to
infuse for 30 minutes drain the liquid
and add the lemon juice then fill it
into a bottle
and keep in the fridge
let's make an indian breakfast curry all
right
one tablespoon of tea a quarter teaspoon
coriander seeds 10 dried perry leaves
until toasted one garlic clove and a
quarter teaspoon of chili powder a
quarter teaspoon turmeric and half a
teaspoon garam masala
then add 2 large tomatoes 1 small
aubergine and half a teaspoon salt
a 10 grams chopped coriander 100
milliliters of water and the eggs cook
for five minutes until thickened
have you ever sliced something without
feeling fully in control over the blade
you've got to change the way you hold
your knife this is my number one tip
that helped me improve my knife skills
alright instead of just holding the
handle use your thumb and index finger
to grip the blade then rest the blade
against your knuckles as a guide and
start slicing this way the knife becomes
an extension of the hand and you have
much more control over how you slice
lots of you couldn't believe that it
would work with anything else but a soft
avocado but it does it works with pretty
much everything like cucumbers carrots
apples onions and even potatoes
oh yes
[Music]
you